welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for our presentation titled tumor
markers and prostate cancer screening
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
victor matey
dr matey is a member of the haifu clinic
medical team and currently works at the
european
institute of technology in milan italy
as the head of
urology training activity and the
institute's premier
robotic surgeon dr mattei has personally
performed over four thousand procedures
including over two thousand endoscopic
procedures and over one thousand robotic
procedures
utilizing the ground-breaking da vinci
robotic system
he has been an adjunct professor at the
urological
residency school at the university of
milan's faculty of medicine
for over 11 years for a complete
biography
on our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box
our speaker will address your questions
following this presentation
please join me in welcoming dr victor
mate
i will now turn the presentation over to
him
okay good morning everybody
i want to start my presentation with
these two
graphics that all you know showing the
effect
of psa introduction into the clinical
practice on prostate cancer incidence
and mortality and the rate of men
presenting with metastatic disease
the reason is that based on this data
the expectation of
significant positive results from a
psa-based screening
were huge the aim of any screening
program
and thus of prostate cancer too is the
early detection of cases
able to undergo radical treatment and
having as
final result the reduction of overall
and cancer-specific mortality as far as
prostate cancer screening is concerned
the high rate of horse negative biopsies
and the high rate of clinical
non-significant disease
might decisively interfere and prevent
to reach the expected mortality
reduction
as a final result of the screening
program
various reviews and meta-analyses of the
european and the u.s screening trials
showed that the benefit is really small
and regards only the cancer-specific
mortality
so to be weighted against the inherent
risk of over-diagnosis
and over-treatment as the psa
is not a tumor marker but an organ
marker
the early detection of potentially
lateral little cases
is counteract by a low specificity
of psa while the risk of overtreat
clinically non-significant disease
is enhanced by the underuse of active
surveillance
based on the evidence of the risk of
over diagnosis and
over treatment and of the treatment
important side effects
the us preventive service task force
issued
in 2012 a great d recommendation
against psa based screening
highlighting the limitations in the
historical implementation of screening
the effects of this recommendation were
a sharp decline of psa tests
of biopsies and the increase of patients
presenting with metastatic disease
with the risk of reversal to the figures
of the pre-psa
era there was an increase of second
testing before biopsy two
and an incentive to find more specific
biomarkers
moreover it was an increasing
understanding of the evidence
that early detection has at least
partially driven the observed
prostate cancer mortality reduction over
time
as a result in 2017 the u.s preventive
services task force upgraded the psa
screening to a great sea recommendation
meaning a balanced approach to prostate
cancer early detection
emphasizing a shared decision
that decision making and appropriate
risk-based management
for men at risk of prostate cancer
concerning both screening
and biopsy performance
if the particular cancer is forget the
high efficiency of all therapeutic means
under asd underestimates
the role of early detection and overall
cancer
survivors can specific survival
correlate strong overall and chances to
specific survival correlates strongly
with the choice of the appropriate
treatment
rather than with an early diagnosis
for the prostate cancer instead the
optimization of diagnosis impacts more
deceasingly
on the cancer-specific survival
rather than the choice of an appropriate
treatment
biomarkers both molecular and majestic
may turn determinant in improving the
efficiency
of the diagnostic process but also
as risk stratification and dust in the
therapeutic strategy
the use of biomarkers in screening and
the optimization
of the diagnostic strategy is need to
avoid
unnecessary biopsies and to improve the
prostate biopsy performance
in favor of clinical significant
[Music]
diseases
as far as the therapeutic aspect is
concerned
the role of biomarkers might be relevant
in risk and just
treatment choice moreover noble
biomarkers have
been implemented to standardize and
appropriate use of
active disturbance
the diagnosis algorithm helps us to
better design
and develop biomarkers in order to
improve the screening process
especially in some critical points
the share of the cheesy making between
the primary care provider neurologist
and patient is the cornerstone of the
actual approach
the risk assessment and stratification
aim to improve the efficiency
of this tailored screening process
risk factors impact both on the
population
to be screened and on the age when the
start of screening
surprisingly looking for the review
articles
dealing with this item during the last
five years
the conclusions are almost the same
despite relentless efforts
the paper this paper written at the end
of the 2015
ones about the need to increase the
accuracy of piecing screening
to find more rapid and specific
detection markers
suggesting as a possible solution the
integration with
genetic tests after
five years this other review
with the same item
concludes identically suggesting as
imperative
to overpass the deadlock the biomarker
combination
as a consequence the research must go on
in fact looking into the body of these
papers some interesting data may be
noted
as previously showed due to its low
specificity
for clinical significant prostate cancer
psa showed itself in surface institution
as the screening mark marker
at least if used alone prostate health
index
for calicrine scroll
combining psa isoforms improve the
area under the curve in the diagnosis
i think gene and clinical data are also
considered
a so-called novel set of markers such as
the
insulin like growth factors
interleukin-6 an intellectual insecure
receptor
even if not promising they
did not found practical application and
the last review does
not even mention them
an interesting chapter is the urine
markers the pca three
received the fda approval to be used in
patients suspicious for prostate cancer
having a first negative biopsy
the genomic rearrangement mostly gene
fusion involving tmprss2
and erg transcription factor
occurs in up to 50 percent of prostate
cancer rations
having a specificity of 93
and a positive productive value of
94 percent
it combines pca3 with tmpr ss2
erg to estimate the risk of prostate
cancer
and thus to help the children making for
prostate biopsy the select
md test is designed to measure rna
levels of two genes
dlx 1 and 0 xc6
exosomes are small extracellular
vesicles
involved in intracellular communication
recent data has shown that first to
mention
mprss2 erg can be detected in
extracellular vesicles from urine
samples
x-406 and integrated with clinical data
extra dx tests
prostates are secretory granules
produced and delivered by prostate cells
allowing the spermatozous survival in
the female genital attract
and finally the recommendation
their ability
their ability
of immunosuppression invasive support
angiogenetic capacity are potentially
cancer promoting properties
and even if
the to assist fertilizing sperm cells
after 50 years of age seemed to turn
against the hostile cell promoting its
malignant transformation
as a result they potentially may become
prostate cancer detection biomarkers
what about
exosomes they are also vesicles
smaller than prostazones containing
micrornas
messenger rna and even viral peptides
content protected by a double membrane
the most
the most important content are the micro
rna
small non-coding single-stranded rna
involved in regulation of mrna
their resistance to rnas
confirms them a sufficient stability
in most body fluids
here you can see microrna involved in my
living transformation of prostate cells
while in this second table
a micro rna involved in preventing it
thus micrornas
seems useful tools not so much for
diagnosis
than as predictors of clinical outcome
of protein
prostate cancer patients
an interesting chapter regards the
tissue markers
the confirmed md test performed on the
tissue obtained from a negative biopsy
and
analyzes the methylation of three
biomarkers
and may turn fundamental in indicating
to repeat the biopsy
here the majestic biomarkers according
to
the two trials performed performing the
multi-parametric mri before the biopsy
it reduces the over detection of
clinical
non-significant disease by 37 percent
missing only four percent and reducing
the biopsy by 32
as this pathway may be cost effective
only
in the long term actually it requires
changes in healthcare system in order to
accommodate
appropriate mri capacity and to
guarantee the training needs for
radiologists and neurologists
as a result the use of molecular
biomarkers
might be might be
useful in selecting patients and thus
limiting the need of performing mri
or in periods three already documented
legends selecting patients worked on the
row biopsy
this suggested even if crowded table
resumes the role and the utility of
previously discussed biomarkers and they
are used in clinical practice
even if all dimension markers outperform
the psa
they think they find limitations in a
rooting use
as a consequence the development of gene
panels
combined with the imaging and clinical
data
may be the solution to implement their
use
the most interesting screening test
seems to be
this one based on the circulating tumor
cells
using immunocytochemistry techniques
here you can see the study design in
this non-randomized study
the positive predictive value and the
negative
predictive value resulted close to 100
percent
clearly superior to the psa and even to
the association psa mri
the combined circulating tumor cell
detection
and immunocytochemistry seems a very
promising promising
screening test waiting to be tested on a
population level
and i conclude emphasizing that nowadays
psa screening has to be
individualized risk adjusted
and associated with the mri in order to
avoid
unnecessary biopsies the circulating
tumor cell indemnification
using immunocytochemistry
techniques seems the more more the most
promising screening test but it needs
further evaluation on population level
finally the integration with genomic
tests such as micro rna
may turn out imperative for bowel
detection
and prediction of clinical outcome
thank you very much and if there are
some questions
i would be happy to answer them
thank you dr mattei for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move on to the live q a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
our first question is why do you think
pfa based screening is not working
so mainly the problems are
allowed specificity for cancer specific
cancer significant significant cancer
patients so with the psa
they were discovered many patients
having clinical
non-significant disease and that's why
at the end of the screening process the
benefit of
reducing the mortality was not evident
because the majority of
patients found with this disease were
clinical
non-significant significance so they
were
they were fit only for active
surveillance and not for treatment
okay and our second question
is what do you think about circulating
tumor cell detection so the
circulating tumor cell detection is a
very promising
method it was of course
used before in discovering if
the disease has or
has not metastases
secondary they it was a very interesting
study about the tumultuous
circulating cells um
showing that there were also
stem cells and natural cells
the use of these cells
these circulating cells tumors tumor
cells
is very promising because the technique
used to find the tumor cells is the
immunocyto chemistry
method that there are used also for
for example in
to see tumor cells in urine
and the technique is very very
easy and very uh
very very good very very reliable
and that's why i think this is one of
the
best techniques to make diagnosis in
this study
there were also patients with second
tumor or with
three tumors
not only prostate cancer but also
kidney cancer or lymphomas so this
method seems
really very promising
well thank you again dr victor mattei
and thank you to the audience for those
outstanding questions
we hope you found today's presentation
to be informative and insightful
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing
don't miss out on the other valuable
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
until next time
goodbye